genauso ist es Florian Bauer guten
Morgen hier aus dem Deutschen Bundestag
von uns also das wird ein Winter der Not
so hat es Vizekanzler Robert Habeck
dieser Tage in einem Interview nochmal
zu Protokoll gegeben darauf müssen wir
uns einstellen die Bundesregierung
versucht dagegen anzuarbeiten mit vielen
Milliarden mit Bremsen und durchaus auch
mit Deckeln das ist das Rezept die Frage
ist wie gut wirkt das gegen die Preise
in der Krise Antworten darauf jetzt von
meinen beiden Gästen ich darf ganz
herzlich begrüßen die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Bündnis grünen
hier im Bundestag Julia Verlinden die
gleichzeitig auch Mitglied der
Expertenkommission für Energie und Wärme
gewesen ist und ich freue mich dass da
als Andreas Jung er ist Sprecher für
Klima und Energiepolitik der
Unionsfraktion und stellvertretender
Parteivorsitzender der CDU hoffe
anfangen die Strom und die
gaspreisbremse heute in der ersten
Lesung es sind auch noch viele andere
Dinge die auf der Tagesordnung sind das
eine Brandmauer gegen
hohe Preissteigerung das sagt der
Wirtschaftsminister mal abgesehen davon
dass das Bild sehr explosiv ist wenn ich
an Feuer und an Gas denke aber das
lassen wir dahin gestellt welche
Garantie dass das jetzt klappt mit dem
was sie angehen also wir haben einen
klaren Zeitplan so dass diese Gas und
strompreisbremsen auch im nächsten Jahr
in Kraft treten und alle Menschen dann
auch sich darauf verlassen können dass
sie an der Stelle ja einen Deckel
bekommen das heißt dass es nicht weiter
steigen wird die Energiepreise im
Bereich Strom Gas und auch Fernwärme und
das ist wichtig um hier auch Sicherheit
zu geben wir haben mit hohen
Energiepreisen auf dem Weltmarkt zu tun
und deswegen ist es richtig hier jetzt
entsprechend gegenzusteuern über
mögliche Mitnahmeeffekte die jetzt schon
im Raum stehen können weil dann später
gleich noch reden wenn wir über die
strompreisbremse sprechen Herr Jung es
gibt von von ihrer Seite ganz konkret
von ihrem Parteien und
Fraktionsvorsitzenden gab es eine
relativ heftige Kritik am Wochenende
kurzatmig und mit ganz heißer Nadel
gestrickt war so etwa die Formulierung
ist das nur eine Kritik am Timing oder
gibt es sozusagen ein strukturelles
Problem dass sie sehen mir ist
offenkundig mit heißer Nagel gestrickt
weil man erst im September begonnen hat
wir wussten ja seit Frühjahr spätestens
im Sommer es gibt eine Preisexplosion
dann hat aber Olaf Scholz erstmal die
gasumlage vorgeschlagen dadurch wurde
der Sommer vertan dann wurde die
Kommission eingesetzt der ist in fast
unzumuntern eurer Zeitdruck gemacht
worden das ist der Blick zurück aber der
hat Auswirkungen heute was dazu führt
dass diese Bremsen die wir brauchen erst
im März kommen und deshalb hat die
Regierung mehrere Notlösungen drum
rumgestrickt dadurch wird es sehr
kompliziert und es droht in der
Umsetzung dass viele Fragen aufgeworfen
werden und dieses Vertrauen dass wir
brauchen eben nicht geschaffen wird das
ist der eine Punkt der zweite Punkt da
wird jetzt gemacht etwas bei Strom und
beim Gas es wird aber nichts gemacht bei
den Menschen und Betrieben die mit Öl
und Pellets heizen die sollen Härtefälle
werden das sind aber keine Härtefälle
das sind ganz viele Menschen und
Betriebe aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft
und deshalb sind Lücken in diesem Paket
gut dass das parlamentarische Verfahren
beginnt ja das ist der Punkt den sie
auch schon länger machen Frau verlinken
im Grunde genommen lag jetzt hier ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt drin nämlich die
Frage ist hat die Regierung hier
unnotwendigerweise Vertrauen verspielt
indem sie wirklich diese Kritik kommt
übrigens auch aus den Ländern das
Planungssicherheit fehlt für die KMU ist
also die kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen zum Beispiel aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern kam ganz konkret
diese Kritik also haben sie einfach ein
bisschen zu wenig Tempo gegeben das
glaube ich nicht also wir sind seit dem
Februar seit diesem schrecklichen
Angriffskrieg ja dabei Entlastungen zu
organisieren das ist ja jetzt auch nicht
die erste Entlastung die auf dem Weg
gebracht wird zahlreiche Milliarden sind
schon ausgeschüttet worden sind schon
bei den Menschen angekommen bei den
Unternehmen angekommen und das ist jetzt
ein weiterer Schritt um sich auf den ja
auf das kommende Jahr vorzubereiten
heute allein ist diese Dezember
Soforthilfe in Kraft getreten das heißt
all diejenigen Menschen die heute
theoretisch ihren Abschlag für ihre
Gasrechnung hätten zahlen müssen müssen
das nicht tun die ein Dauerauftrag haben
beispielsweise konnten diesen
zurückziehen für den Dezember bzw es
wurde nicht eingezogen von den
Energieversorgern und diejenigen die
über ihre Vermieter abgerechnet werden
die bekommen das Geld entsprechend
zurück über ihre Nebenkostenabrechnung
das heißt die dezemberzahlungen für Gas
und Fernwärme hat der Staat übernommen
und das heißt diese Entlastung ist auch
heute bei den Menschen schon angekommen
wenn ich direkt einen Vertrag habe mit
meinem Versorger bin ich ein Mieter in
einer Mietwohnung bin dann muss ich
darauf warten bis nächsten Dezember bis
der Vermieter entsprechend über den
Nebenkostenabrechnung kommt kommt ein
bisschen drauf an wenn bereits eine
Erhöhung stattgefunden hat dann kann ich
jetzt bereits schon meinen Abschlag
reduzieren das sind verschiedene
Rahmenbedingungen der Vermieter hatte
mich übrigens dann darüber informieren
müssen wie das jetzt ab heute aussieht
wenn ich eben in einer Mietwohnung lebe
dann schaue ich heute mal in meinem
Briefkasten ähm vor verlinken wenn wir
beide jetzt hier rausgehen aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag mal abgesehen davon
dass relativ kalt ist gerade aktuell in
Berlin und diese harte Winter eigentlich
schon beginnt dann würden wir
wahrscheinlich ein Problem haben
jemanden zu finden der uns ad hoc
erklären kann die Funktionsweise dieses
doch recht komplizierten Konstrukt also
hat die Politik da jetzt wirklich ein
Problem auch wieder mit dem Erklären von
dem ganzen
nun wir hatten die Erwartungen zu
erfüllen dass wir sehr schnell handeln
und das ist auch gut funktioniert und
deswegen sind wir in der
Expertenkommission Gas und Wärme zu dem
Schluss gekommen dass es sinnvoll ist
über die Energieversorger zu gehen denn
die haben alle Kundendaten die haben
alle Kontoverbindungen und wenn die
Energieversorger ab nächstem Jahr
deutlich weniger
einziehen weniger Geld abbuchen bei den
Menschen für Strom Gas und Fernwärme
dann ist es ein sehr praktikables
Vorgehen es ist ein Instrument was
schnell funktioniert und was natürlich
jetzt erstmal auch noch von den
Energieversorgern umgesetzt wird aber
wir haben den Vorteil dass wir im
Gesetzentwurf auch stehen haben das ist
auch rückwirkend gilt also das heißt
auch die Monate Februar und Januar
werden dann im März verrechnet heute ist
noch nichts in der Börse weil sie gerade
so ein bisschen den Raum gestellt haben
nicht dass jemand jetzt schaut und
enttäuscht ist sondern es ist noch Frist
bis März bis dann was fließt sie haben
schon die Kritik gemacht das Timings
jetzt könnten wir natürlich noch mal
fragen nach dem strukturellen Punkt also
hätten Sie es denn grundsätzlich anders
gemacht abgesehen davon dass sie
schneller gemacht hätten wenn sie an
charge werden wir halten die
Konstruktion von Strom und
gaspreisbremse im Grundsatz für richtig
das ist ja auch ein Vorschlag der
zurückgeht auf die Kommission da sind
sehr viele kluge Menschen mit guten
Gedanken dabei gewesen das halten wir im
Grundsatz für richtig wir glauben aber
dass Gruppen außen vor gelassen werden
Öl und Pellets erwähnt dass die
einfachen Dinge nicht gemacht werden
warum macht man nicht das klare Signal
die Mehrwertsteuer geht runter auf alle
Energieträger auf alle auch etwa auf
Strom der der umgestellt hat von Gas auf
Strom der bleibt beim hohen
Mehrwertsteuersatz und der bei Gas hätte
niedrigen das passt doch nicht zusammen
und unsere Kritik bezieht sich vor allem
dann auch auf den Teil wo eine
Erneuerbaren Bremse vorgelegt wird mit
dem abschöpfungsmechanismus sie haben
gesagt er ist manches kompliziert da
haben wir einen gemeinsamen europäischen
Rahmen aber niemand macht so kompliziert
in Deutschland wir sind auf dem Weg zur
Europa Meisterschaft in komplizierter
Umsetzung aber wir wollen doch vorreit
bei den Erneuerbaren sein die werden
aber hier abgewürgt und sie werden
schlechter behandelt als die fossilen
sie werden schlechter behandelt als die
Kernenergie und deshalb braucht es
gerade an diesem Punkt veränderungs muss
es klare Signal geben das was man mit
dem osterpaket beschleunigen wollte das
wird jetzt nicht im Winter wieder
eingerissen also da ist eine ganz
konkrete Kritik übrigens ist natürlich
der Europa mit dem Boot und wir haben
einmal schon bei Mehrwertsteuer Fragen
erlebt dass das gar nicht so einfach ist
irgendwas abzusenken was man möchte weil
Europa könnte man sofort beschließen
heute im Bundestag warum machen wir
nicht einfach also ich glaube es ist
jetzt für die Menschen weniger relevant
an welcher Stelle die Entlastung
tatsächlich umgesetzt wird ob das an der
Mehrwertsteuer hängt oder ob wir den
Strompreis Deckeln auf einen bestimmten
Betrag die EEG-Umlage beispielsweise
haben wir im Sommer bereits abgeschafft
das war auch eine Entlastung von
mehreren Cent pro Kilowattstunde das
heißt am Ende ist kommt es darauf an wie
viel kostet die Kilowattstunde und ob
das an welcher Stelle jetzt geschraubt
wird ist glaube ich für die Menschen
weniger relevant sondern wichtig ist sie
können sich jetzt auf einen Strompreis
Verlassen der das ganze das nächste Jahr
gilt der gilt bis
diese Krise sozusagen auch überwunden
ist die wir aktuell haben und deswegen
ist es notwendig hier jetzt schnell in
die Umsetzung zu kommen aber ich gebe
Ihnen Recht wir müssen an der Stelle
wie finanzieren wir die strompreisbremse
und an welcher Stelle schöpfen wir die
sogenannten zufallsgewinne von den
Energieerzeugern also von den
stromerzeuern ab da müssen wir noch mal
genauer hinschauen dass das keine neuen
Investitionen in erneuerbare verhindert
weil das wäre natürlich die schlechteste
Botschaft und deswegen schauen wir da im
parlamentarischen Verfahren auch noch
mal ganz genau hin die Klagewelle von
der Solarbranche ist mehr oder weniger
bereits angedroht dem sehen Sie gelassen
entgegen ja wir wie gesagt wir prüfen
das jetzt im parlamentarischen Verfahren
ob da an einer Stelle noch mal
nachjustiert werden muss aber wie gesagt
dazu sind wir intensiven Gesprächen
gerade die Debatte fängt ja jetzt heute
an es gibt etwas anderes wir sind ja im
Grunde genommen jetzt schon in der
Wechselstube hier zwischen Gas und Strom
und das ist ja auch immer nur zusammen
zu denken wie sie auch festgestellt
haben Herr Jung es gibt eine massive
Kritik die auch durchaus ernst zu nehmen
ist weil sie auch ans Konstrukt dran
geht die sagt eigentlich bietet das
ganze so wie es aufgebaut ist nicht
genügend Sparanreize also wenn ich mit
einem hohen Wert komme an Verbrauch habe
ich trotzdem diese 80 Prozent die
einfach mal einfach gedeckelt sind und
wenn ich bisher schon gespart habe
bringt mir das nicht so furchtbar viel
hätte man das irgendwie schlauer machen
können ich finde das ist ja die
Konstruktion die die Kommission
vorgeschlagen hat eine Deckelung nicht
auf das Niveau vor der Krise sondern auf
ein Niveau des nach der Krise erwartet
wird niemand weiß wie es genau ist aber
es ist doch noch mal erheblich mehr als
vor der Krise und nicht zu 100% sondern
zu 80%, das heißt im guten Teil müssen
Marktpreis sie dann eben doch bezahlt
werden und da hat man bei den aktuellen
Preisen ein spar-anhalt und deshalb im
Grundsatz wie gesagt hätten wir diese
Konstruktion für richtig weil sie
mehrere Dinge zusammenbringt auch
übrigens die Frage wenn wir jetzt als
Stadt Eingreifen was ist in dieser
Situation ausdrücklich notwendig ist wie
kommen wir da wieder raus und wenn diese
Preise die erwartet werden tatsächlich
erreicht werden 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde beim Gas dann wird es
automatisch abgeschafft werden deshalb
ja man kann ein Muster über nachdenken
was kann man noch mehr für sparen für
Effizienz tun in
Betrieben und bei Privathaushalten aber
im Grundsatz ist an diesem Punkt die
Konstruktion sehr nachvollziehbar und
ich finde zusätzlich müssen natürlich
auch Investitionen getätigt werden also
es kann ja nicht die Dauerlösung sein
dass sozusagen diese hohen dass wir
insgesamt als Gesellschaft gegen diese
hohen Energiepreise an subventionieren
sondern es muss dringend mehr dafür
getan werden das auch Vermieter in die
Sanierung der Häuser investieren weil
die MieterInnen eingegangen also wir
sind alleine bei den Bremsen bei einem
höheren zweistelligen ähm
Milliardenbetrag so hat das ja habe
gesagt glaube 56 oder so statt dem Raum
und da kann natürlich was drauf kommen
es gibt immer so besondere Gruppen die
man manchmal vergisst und dann kommen
sie wieder bisschen rein eine Gruppe
sozusagen die jungen Menschen in
Ausbildung sage ich jetzt einfach mal
ich mache es mal relativ komplett da ist
was schönes angedacht für Studenten
Studentinnen Fachausbildung etc das
ganze ist nur ein bisschen blöd ich muss
das auf einer digitalen Plattform
anmelden die es noch gar nicht gibt Frau
Verlinden
es wird umgesetzt und das Geld wird bei
den Menschen ankommen okay jetzt haben
wir wenn wir in den Schlusskurve gehen
Herr Jung noch mal die Chance zu reden
über sagen wir mal unseren Energiemix
der Zukunft es bringt ja nichts wenn du
heute den heutigen Tag denken jetzt
haben wir eine eine neue Lösung Katar
will uns Flüssiggas liefern 2026 das ist
so ein Sichtweite aber es ist jetzt
nicht direkt was für den nächsten Winter
wie was machen wir eigentlich aus dieser
Balance von Abhängigkeiten sozusagen
sind wir quasi bei dem einen aus dem
Bett gesprungen und gehen mit dem
nächsten sagen wir mal halb seinem
Bruder zu Bett in die Antwort auf
einseitige Abhängigkeiten die bei den
fossilen entstanden sind bei Russland
müssen ganz breit die Partnerschaften
sein vor allem beim Wasserstoff die sind
ja auch auf dem Weg gebracht schon in
den letzten Jahren die müssen jetzt
konsequent fortgeführt werden auf dem
Weg dahin brauchen wir Gas als Brücke da
ist wichtig dass eben sehr
verteilt wird dass wir nicht einen oder
nur wenige große Lieferanten haben
sondern das jetzt gelingt er einen ein
der zweiten Strauß an Lieferbeziehungen
aufzubauen aber entscheidend ist dass
wir jetzt die Dinge die wir angegangen
haben erneuerbare Energien
Energieeffizienz wasserstoffstrategie
dass die konsequent vorangebracht werden
dass die beschleunigt werden mit einem
verlässlichen Rahmen für die
Energieeffizienz aber auch dadurch dass
wir den Erneuerbaren jetzt Vertrauen
geben Verlässlichkeit geben und dieses
Vertrauen wird durch den Vorschlag zur
Abschöpfung beschädigt und deshalb ist
gut das war verlinken angekündigt hat
wie auch Abgeordnete Ampel gestern im
Ausschuss das schaut man noch mal
gemeinsam drauf so wie es ist kann es
nicht bleiben
[Musik]
solange das Präsidium noch nicht da ist
können wir noch einen Punkt weiter
sprechen also es gibt quasi noch diesen
Punkt mit diesem Flüssigkeiten das war
ja kein liebes Mutter ist für die Grünen
auch sie gehen jetzt quasi noch mal
eigentlich den Weg in die falsche
Richtung
es ist wichtig dass diejenigen die jetzt
privatwirtschaftliche Entscheidungen
treffen genau im Blick haben dass wir
ein ja eine Klimaschutzpolitik
fortsetzen die dazu führen wird dass
deutlich weniger gasverbraucht wird in
den nächsten Jahren schon wird der
Gasverbrauch zurückgehen denn ja wir
müssen die Klimaziele schaffen und dazu
führt eben raus aus den fossilen und
deswegen ist die Langfristigkeit von
Investitionsentscheidungen eine sehr
knifflige Angelegenheit wo die
Unternehmen die daran investieren gut
nachdenken müssen was langfristig
funktioniert ich habe zu danken an Julia
verlinken Andreas Jung sie als Politik
haben noch viel auf der Brust 9 % nur
der Deutschen glauben dass diese
entlastungsorgien wirklich eine
entlastungsbringe am Ende da ist noch
viel Vertrauensarbeit nötig danke dass
Sie bei uns waren